dass diese neue mercedes benz e ist ein
batterieelektrische hause von mercedes
hier ist jetzt diese ladebuchse die das
tun wir jetzt mal das runter ist
natürlich alles nass ja aber gut es wird
ja hoffentlich keinen stromschlag geben
wird angelastet
wir sind damit jetzt auf einer fahrt von
frankfurt nach münchen
der kospi führen
das kochen sind scharf auf der autobahn
brauchen elektroauto da ziemlich viel
strom ins headquarter das was haben es
nicht schaffen müssen wir prüfen hier
das ist jetzt schon ganz ordentlich
jetzt werden über 100 kilowatt
eingefüllt allerdings gibt es nun das
und deswegen stehen wir auch im freien
und wir gehen dann jetzt gleich mal rein
und essen nach einer kleinigkeit denn
wir werden hier eine stunde zu bringen
man muss die sollen immer ein bisschen
suchen also auch hier haben china fonds
stehen die ziemlich weit hinten hinter
der tankstelle
aber da sind sie neben der autobahn hier
steht auch schon ein audi der lädt und
wir auch wir sind jetzt mit 55 km
restreichweite hier angekommen und man
empfiehlt uns eine halbe stunde zu laden
rein natürlich auch die aufgeht ist die
trickboxx gegangen ist sichtlich und
stecker wird zwar verriegelt dunkel
und mittendrin gucken ja mal erlebt na
gut dann setzen wir doch uns ins auto
wieder rein heißt es ein bisschen
trockener und mit nachher mit fast 800
kilometer gefahren einmal frankfurt
münchen frankfurt
kurzum das auto fährt sehr gut
solide ein mercedes hat hof selb
plazenta
ich bin ein ganz kurzer moment
also man sieht auch gut gedämmt insofern
spielt er die vorteile des elektroautos
aus
zum elektrischen fahren kann man sagen
sehr harmonisch aber
die langstrecken tauglichkeit macht uns
zu schaffen wir haben jetzt ein
durchschnittsverbrauch von 29,3
gigawattstunden
und wenn man schneller als 130 140 so
diese der täter dann kommen wir 220 km/h
zurück wer jetzt eine ganze weile 110
120 gefahren haben wir 280 kilometer
geschafft mehr ist nicht drin
dann muss man zum laden
haben auf dem hinweg eine stunde 20
durch narben verbraucht und auf dem
rückweg eine stunde
die muss man eben dazu zählen
das finde ich jetzt nicht so richtig
überzeugend für ein auto bei 70.000 euro
kostet
und was 400 kilometern reichweite hat
und dann muss man noch ganz besonders
auf eine sache achten
wenn man es an die heimische wall box
anschließt
dann nimmt der wagen nur 7,2 kw auf
serienmäßig schneller lässt mercedes mit
dem serienmäßigen roger nicht zu
das finde ich enttäuschend das sollte
nicht sein der wagen muss an der wall
box schneller laden
meldet sich dort im bus hier was kann
ich für sie tun gar nichts das ding
nervt und immer wenn man das wort
mercedes sachen sprechers an
jetzt schaut wieder das ist auch die bis
heute
ansonsten sind wir ziemlich zufrieden
mit dem wagen und jetzt muss jeder
selbst entscheiden ob das von ihnen das
rechtens